[Music]
hello and welcome to episode number 205
of the weekly Google cloud platform
podcast i am asha and i am here with my
colleague brian hey Brian
hello aza so later today we have an
interview with two of our colleagues
jazz Nathan that is awesome they're
gonna teach us all about the DevOps and
what's our question of the week about
this week Brian
it is what actually is the cloud sequel
proxy and why does one even want to such
a thing yes we will get to that later
but first my favorite part of the
podcast every week cool thing of the
week first a cool thing is the odd next
London just happened and I was there and
it was cool it was a really high energy
and there was lots of stuff announced
and everyone was just an absolute
delight to talk abou I got to answer and
ask a lot of really cool questions
people had questions for the panel that
I ran but Brian actually has spent more
time looking over the entire list of
stuff that was announced so Brian do you
want to talk a little bit about what you
noticed sure I got all this from a kind
of a wrap up blog post that we made so
it's worth checking out it's a wrap key
announcements from next 19 UK and we're
gonna have a link to that in the show
notes but big picture I thought there's
a lot of small things and it feels like
the theme was like bringing cloud and
your on-premise data centers closer
together so along those lines things
about bringing existing IP addresses
that you may have and not be able to
change configuration around you can
actually bring those to GCP and make
them part of GCP you can rent bare metal
machines kind of like in racks that are
like network wise and physically very
close to Google interconnects if you
need to run something you have complete
control over but also like really fast
pipe some more network monitoring things
are on hybrid Apps migration tools for
migrating existing machines to cloud VMs
or into containers on kubernetes and
what-have-you and cloud run for anthos
was announced so like a bunch of stuff
in that theme of connecting things and
then I also wanted to highlight around
the AI and Mel stuff you know I'm
definitely no expert in the space but it
it seems like one of the ongoing
challenges is just understanding the
models and the team has done a ton of
work under the umbrella of explainable
AI it's really worth checking out if
you're involved in that space at all and
AUSA my question for you is while you
were there did you get T I did get T
ahead T with some of the Googlers the
day before the conference and it was
amazing
it was so good that is fantastic
I was in Denver last week and had
afternoon tea but it was not in London
so a little bit jealous
what's your cool thing of the week my
cool thing of the week one of our former
colleagues who is now working on open
source Ecole Julie appointed me at a
blog post that talks about how you can
take graph his diagrams and using an
extension make them look hand-drawn and
I've done a bunch of stuff with Graff is
over the years and my most recent thing
was a blog post I did on taking cloud
bill files and showing the dependencies
using graph is by creating a dot file
that I did for mark module the former
lead host of a podcast and now I can
make them look like I hand drew them and
for someone who does not draw straight
lines without a ruler very well this is
awesome so there'll be a link in the
show notes to this particular blog post
from showing how to do this oh that's
super cool I love love love that in fact
just this weekend I noticed in
matplotlib this graphing library for
Python it has a mode to enable xkcd
comic style sketchy graphs so in that
same theme I love the fact that we have
made things to make our digitally
generated things look like they were not
digitally generated we have a come full
circle it's awesome it's bring a little
more humanity into all the things on
that note let's switch to the
conversation with Nathan and Jezz about
DevOps okay so super excited to have
both Nathan and just here today
can I ask you each to introduce yourself
quickly and your connection to DevOps so
we'll start with Nathan great hi my name
is Nathan Harvey and I am a developer
advocate here at Google cloud and the
area where I focus is on the DevOps and
sree community so what's my background
with DevOps I've been sort of circling
in and around the
DevOps community for I don't know eight
or nine years and I used to be a dev op
I don't believe you can be a DevOps
but I used to be so what does that mean
it means that I used to be responsible
for managing operations at a online
retailer and you know we would build
deploy manage applications it helped
manage the infrastructure we were moving
from the data center into the cloud and
then eventually I left that job and
became a developer advocate or a
community organizer and have been
spending the last eight years in that
space excellent I am also working in dev
rel as a developer advocate my
connection to DevOps is that I
co-authored a book called continues
livery which came out around the same
time that the devil's movement was
really starting to be a thing to me
something we actually got DevOps into
the book and it was the first published
but that actually mentions DevOps I
think as far as I know I'm also going
through the DevOps handbook and of
accelerate which is a book based on a
research program that myself adopts
Nicole for and who's also at Google
along with a bunch of other folks
including the people at puppet have been
working on for the last six years which
looks at how they measure software
delivery performance the factors that
impact it and why it's important a bunch
of that research is up at cloud
google.com slash DevOps along with the
last six years of stated level supports
so we're gonna kick this off with the
easy question what is DevOps well the
first thing to say is that there is no
definition of DevOps and that's on
purpose the people who really I guess we
can say are the founders of the movement
which is Patrick Dubois and Andrew
Schaeffer they deliberately didn't want
there to be a definition of DevOps there
has to be a manifesto they didn't want
any of that stuff because they had seen
what happens the add-on movement where
it basically got taken over by a whole
bunch of people and kind of deployed in
order to make money and sell people
stuff and all this kind of things
they're not doing that we want this to
be a I guess what today would call a
community of practice basically if
people who were trying to get better
building operating distributed systems
at scale that was secure and reliable
and that's when I'm asked if
that's how I normally define it it's a
community of practice trying to solve a
particular problem which is how do we
build large-scale
distributed systems that are secure
resilient however everyone so definition
we have a definition at cleric
google.com DevOps it's one we made up by
ourselves and it says there was an
organizational and cultural movement
that aims to increase software delivery
velocity improve service reliability and
build shared ownership among software
stakeholders which is as good as any I
think I don't hate it I quite like it
Nathan my stuff thoughts on this sure I
have at least three other definitions
that I'll run you through right now
that's not actually true I'm not going
to run you through three other
definitions but I always like to like
when I'm asked to define DevOps I for
better or worse just like to become a
little bit of a historian and say well
how did that word actually come into
being and there are kind of two almost
simultaneous origin stories one is that
John auspi and Paul Hammond gave a talk
at velocity and the talk was titled
something like ten deploys a day and
there was a slide in that talk that on
one side had dev on the other side how
to ops and in the middle had a heart so
that's one part of the origin story of
the term DevOps
the other part is that at an agile
conference there was a birds of a
feather session and I think it was
Andrew clay Schafer proposed a topic at
that birds of a feather session called
agile infrastructure and then he
realized that no one at the agile
conference was going to show up for that
so he skipped his own birds of a feather
session and Patrick Dubois did show up
so eventually they met and then Patrick
started this whole that like coined the
term DevOps by starting a conference
called DevOps days but the interesting
thing at that time I think the reason
that it was called DevOps was because we
kind of recognized this wall of
confusion between dev and ops and the
way that I always talk about it is it's
about how we align those incentives
right so we tell developers your job is
to build features and like make the
customer happy and then we turn to
operations and we say your job is to
keep the system stable and so what does
that do that turns the developers into
push push push push push
and the operators into
stop piston keep the system stable what
I will do is accept no changes in the
system and that became a real problem
so DevOps was born from how do we
actually stop this throwing stuff over
the wall of confusion from dev to ops
but instead get Devon ops to realize
that what they're both here to do is
focus on the customer and so today I
really look at and why sort of DevOps is
this cultural movement I really look at
it as this is how we can actually get IT
to align to the business and understand
what is the business objective and so I
think DevOps is a terrible word yeah so
one interesting historical book most of
that is we've just had the very last
velocity conference in Berlin this year
in as much as one book end of this
movement was the first velocity
conference in 2009 we just finished it
off and of course you know that was
co-founded by John Wallace Paul and
Steve so deserve Google
speaking of conferences the DevOps news
conference recently celebrated his ten
year anniversary and I am ashamed to
admit that I remember the first step
offstage Seattle happening and being
very confused as to what that was
what's the devops days that is a great
question aza
so a DevOps days as you mentioned it
celebrated its 10-year anniversary
there's a really interesting thing I
think first we'll just start with sort
of the format of a DevOps days so a
DevOps days is a locally organized
conference which is why you know there
have been many in Seattle there have
been many in Washington DC all over the
world these conferences happen but the
key behind a DevOps days conference is
really to celebrate the idea of bringing
a cross-functional group of humans
together to collaborate on what are the
things that are top of mind around how
do you do IT better how do you dev up
how do you align better with the
business strategy what are the cultural
changes that you need to bring into your
organization and in order to really help
with that collaboration a typical DevOps
days includes about half predetermined
content so talks from presenters that
are maybe like keynotes or 30-minute
talks and then also some ignite talks
which are nice five minutes
inspire us but keep it short but the
other half of the conference is where it
gets really really interesting the
conference organizers kind of turn over
the conference to the attendees of that
conference and it's typically done
through a process called open spaces and
in open spaces every participant at the
conference is invited to propose a talk
or a propose a topic a topic that
they're interested in learning more
about something that they want to share
and the only rule is you have to be
passionate enough about that topic to
start a conversation from there the
participants kind of self organize into
small discussion groups and talk about
each one of those topics and so the idea
behind it is really that practitioners
the people that are out there making
these changes within their organizations
are sharing with one another
exactly what they're doing where they're
running into friction how they're
overcoming that friction and it's a
really great conference series to help
you connect with your local community
and drive sort of the practice of DevOps
and the principles of DevOps forward
within your organization okay I think I
get it now you have done a good sales
pitch for the DevOps news conference
series all right one of the other
interesting things I think about it is
it's truly locally organized so in 2019
I think there were 80 DevOps days that
happened mobili yeah I see that look on
your face none of the podcast listeners
can see that look on your face but it is
what I'm making a giant shock face
indeed and the way that that works is
each one is locally organized by a local
group of volunteers there is a global
organizing committee of which I happen
to be a part of but our role as the
global organizers is really to provide
some of the infrastructure like the
website some coaching on what should
your agenda look like and some guidance
on that but each one is locally
organized operated and executed huit
okay since we're mining things other
people said like there was this mention
of like the accelerate state of DevOps
report and that sounds important and big
and you mentioned research
so I'm curious like what is this thing
yes a state of DevOps report you kind of
slide off as a kind of industry report
produced by puppet labs as it was back
in the day hands at the very first time
I think I was involved in year two and
when we were presenting after year two
someone walked up to one of the
organizers at puppet confirm was like
hey you know that you're doing it wrong
the people there were like well that's
interesting and who you and this person
was like well I'm dr. Nicole Foster and
I am a researcher at our State
University and professor at Utah State
University who does stuff on systems
administration I do research on systems
administration amongst other things and
you know I'm a statistician and this
person was smart enough to say well
maybe used to come and talk to people
who do it and be involved in that and so
in year three 2014 nikohl joined us and
injected basically statistical and
methodological rigor into it and so it
ended up being this research driven
academically rigorous program looking
into how you measure software delivery
performance the impacts of that the
things that impact software delivery
performance and so over the last six
years we've built I think more than
30,000 data points or observations by
this point from all different kinds of
companies of all different domains and
sizes and we have a actually a pretty
good idea of how you get better at doing
software delivery and we have data and
research that makes that useful and
applicable but where does the research
show that's a great question we actually
have what we lovingly refer to as the
BFD or the big and fulsome diagram which
is currently in the process of being
revised and you podcast users may be
able to see this why I'm holding up it's
a this huge big piece of paper with lots
of arrows and boxes and words it looks
like scary UML yes and the reason that I
have this is because we're revising it
to include the 2019 findings and some
poor person that Google is going to be
tasked with turning this into something
kind of beautiful and friendly that you
can print out and put but
your desk or you know frame and hang
above your bed for that matter you know
if that's what does it fee and I mean
broadly speaking what it does is it
shows you what helps you get better
Assaf livery performance and there's
basically four groups of things a whole
bunch of technical practices that we
lovingly call continuous delivery
obviously because that was me
say things like is he is testing at
least a couple architecture building
security into the Safa delivery process
deployment automation trunk based
development and a bunch of other things
some lean management practices like
managing work in process limiting work
in process visual management feedback
from production some lean product
development practices like working in
small batches and making the flow work
visible and a whole bunch of cultural
stuff like for example retrospectives or
post mortems
creating autonomous teams and so forth
and we've so that all those things
impact soft delivery performance some of
them also lead to less burnout teams and
less deployment pain and less rework
some of them increased job satisfaction
software delivery performance in turn
increases organizational performance so
we know that getting better at soccer
delivery makes your organization more
effective as well so basically says well
you know if you want to get better of
this here are all the things that you
need to do to get better at it sounds
like I should read more than the first
10 pages there's a lot it's it's
definitely a rabbit hole that you can
dive into and skip very deep into I will
say that the parts of it I've read have
been incredibly insightful and have made
me think about not just the operation
side but software in general and
cultures around software teams in a very
different way great thank you and we I
mean we've drawn on Google's research as
well one of the things that Google's
famous for is for at Aristotle the
research on how to build high-performing
teams at Google we've been able to
replicate that research this year we
looked at code maintainability using
stuff from Google's internal programs so
a lot of it actually is replicated stuff
that has been found in Google but I
think what's important about it is you
know a lot of people say well your
Google you're special you can do this
stuff we're different and I think what
this program does is say well actually
you can do this stuff anywhere it's not
just applicable at Google anyone can get
better and of course the four of us work
at Google and all
we know that google never has problems
developers you know putting features as
fast as possible and you know being
incentivized based on building things
that might not necessarily be easy to
operate now so Google's obviously a
perfect unicorn we never have any
internal issues and we are special and
brilliant okay so you've got all this
research it shows some stuffs what
should people do with that how do you
apply this I think you're asking when
would I ever use this or some variation
there yeah or why bother reading it or
like what should I do with this stuff
yeah I would love to answer that
question for you
but I'd also love to answer it not yet
podcast DevOps are you trying to get a
second podcast episode no I don't want
to get a second podcast maybe I do but I
just wanted to summarize one quick thing
that the research has shown us over time
so like just mention that oh we're
Google so that probably doesn't apply or
you're from Google that probably doesn't
apply here each year the report looks at
a couple of different things but there
has been a consistent thread throughout
the years and that is looking at things
like lead time and deployment frequency
which you know if you say there were
devops you might think of as the dev
side and then the change fail rate so
when you push something to production
how often does it fail or the time to
restore and to me both of those feel war
on the operations side and so jazz the
research shows us that we can either do
one or the other right we can either
move fast or we can be reliable is that
right absolutely not Nathan in fact
quite the opposite it shows that high
performers do better about speed and
stability it's not in fact a trade-off
and every year we get all this data and
we pop it into it you can kind of think
it was a statistical you know harry
potter
magic Hat's call cluster analysis and
what cluster analysis does is it
basically sorts the participants into
groups and we don't tell it how many
groups to create or what those groups
should look like but we just say here's
four variables make groups out of them
and we always end up with you know three
or four groups and what's interesting is
it's always the case that there's one
group
that does really well on those four
metrics deploy frequency lead time time
to restore change fail rate and one
great that really does really badly on
those four and then one of two groups in
between that kind of in the middle so so
forth so every year we kind of hold our
breath and were like you know what's
gonna pop out this year and every year
the same thing pops up which is really
cool because it validates that that
finding them actually high performers do
better with speed and stability like
performers do badly at speed and
stability and the practices that help
you get better if you do it right help
you get faster and more secure and more
available okay so tell me if I'm wrong
here I think the thing to do actually is
for people who may be listening here
know that thinking more carefully about
kind of some of this DevOps stuff is
better that you can have both speed and
agility they're trying to convince other
people on their teams or their their
management folks the thing to do is like
get them to read this report because
it's actually really readable and based
on research maybe that's the thing yes
exactly and it's actually designed in
such a way that you can do that so the
PDF is quite big I think it's over 80
pages this year but it's design in such
a way that if there's a particular point
that you want to make to your boss
there's like a couple of pages that you
can just print out and lovingly you know
foe carelessly put on their desk this
just happened to end up here yeah
mysterious you know here's your tea and
here's a like a log coaster to put your
tea on oh and look it's got these
diagrams on it so it's definitely
designed to be able to do that you know
in as much as people are persuaded by
day so I think you know in the software
industry we like to think we're data
oriented often we're not we're kind of
fashion and peer persuaded or influenced
but in as much as people can be
influenced by days from research that's
the goal and so Brian coming back to
your question about how do I actually
take this research and put it to work
you know just mentioned throwing a copy
of it on your boss's desk that is a
great first step but the other things
that you can do if you go to cloud
google.com slash DevOps in addition to
being able to download the report there
there's also what we call a DevOps quick
check and we will ask you a series of
five questions and then we will show you
where do you fit in terms of your
industry and in terms of the research
that we've found we will put your
organization as a
low performer a medium performer a high
performer or an elite performer and it
is across those four key metrics that we
talked about and once you understand
that that will also give you some
insight onto where you should probably
focus your effort and so on that same
page we have a collection of key
capabilities that jazz was mentioning
around technical capabilities cultural
capabilities and so forth so really the
idea there is that you focus your
resources on what's currently holding
you back identify some constraints
choose a target and iterate make those a
little bit better get a little bit
better around this capability and then
reflect and do that same thing again so
this is an iterative process the truth
is that when you start your DevOps
transformation and I put that in air
quotes you're never done it is a journey
you don't wake up one day and say well
now we're DevOps so what's next so it's
like everything else in software
shipping it is not actually the
interesting part it's how you keep it
going and and prove it and iterate on it
and make it meet the needs of the humans
who have to use it as life goes on
that's the cool part yes okay is there
anything we missed that you would like
to mention before we wrap things up I
think the only thing I want to say is
just want to pour one out for velocity
since it was just recently the last one
I suddenly learn a ton from velocity is
hugely influential amazing people talked
about amazing things in there so thanks
to everyone involved in that conference
over the years and rest in peace
velocity hey Nathan how about you where
did we miss yeah I would say that you
know we talked a little bit about
velocity again I share the condolences
and like best wishes for velocity in
that team DevOps days did celebrate its
10-year anniversary and so that
conference series is still going but
also this year the DevOps Enterprise
Summit celebrated its fifth year
anniversary so that's another great
conference so I think if you're
interested in learning more about
bringing these practices into your own
organization the place to start right
now is cloud google.com slash DevOps and
then once you've sort of look
some of that research and gathered some
of that information if you're ready to
go to a conference find a local DevOps
days which you can always find at DevOps
days dot work or look to the DevOps
Enterprise summit which typically
happens twice a year but yeah first
definitely feast on the yummy DevOps
goodness there's so much so much great
content there and this is why when I
found that I got into b2 for the podcast
I was excited I just want to share with
everybody that like what I think was a
joke about like not it on the noses has
been in actual practice through this
entire area so the last question we
always ask Wix obviously I'm hoping you
all will get some new fans bring on the
podcast so if y'all find new fans where
can they find you online in person any
of the above and I'm gonna make Nathan
go first
awesome you can find me online probably
easiest through my Twitter handle or you
could look at github or what have you
they're all the same it's always Nathan
Harvey everywhere but I have to warn you
my father misspelled my name so it's n a
th en har vu i we can put that in the
show notes but that's the best place to
find me online and then in person well
it really depends on when this recording
comes out by the time it comes out you
probably missed me at devops days go
away and at next UK but in the future I
will definitely be at DevOps days
conferences I also know that jazz and I
will happen to be together at a
conference in January the delivery comp
that's happening in Seattle yeah so I am
Jays humble everyone on the Internet oh
and was jazz humble which I know Jez and
then humble I don't really get out very
much just probably for the best
but you can see me at conferences where
I am and delivery confess probably the
next one to be honest before you'll be
our next let's face it and that is its
it delivery calm calm it's January 21st
and 22nd in Seattle I promise we will
roll out the wonderful winter weather
for y'all cool I want to thank you guys
this was delightful and amusing and
DevOps is often seen as a really boring
topic but everyone I know who works in
this space
is awesome so I have no idea how it got
that reputation but thank you for
representing that this is about people
and this it's just about making
everything better for everyone involved
Thanks we work very hard to make it
boring yeah and I think a lot of that
has to do with the name it's not about
dev and ops it's all of us so it's even
call it modern you can call it digital
you can call it IT someday we'll stop
using the word cuz it'll just be the way
that things get done software and
feelings okay well thanks y'all thank
you so much thank you so as you can tell
Brian and I had a great time talking to
Nathan and jazz because they are awesome
and DevOps is just such a human topic
that it makes for really easy
conversation despite the fact that
everyone kind of thinks of it is this
deeply technical very nerdy very serious
space I really like the amount of
humanity in the Nathan and just bring
toge is why I really like talking to
them about the topic and now it is time
for the question of the week and Brian
has agreed to be the person who asks the
question this week so that I can be the
person who gets to answer it which is
super appropriate because I don't know
the answer and I don't have to play dumb
I'm actually dumb or wrong way to say
that but I don't know the answer um so
there's this thing called the cloud
sequel proxy that it seems like you need
whenever you want to talk to cloud
sequel why like where does it sit what
is it for I don't understand so the
first thing to know is that you don't
need it it is just the most recommended
way of accessing cloud sequel and to
kind of give an answer to this I'm gonna
use a little bit of my history in tech
so back in the day before I was at
Google actually before it was even at
the job before I was at Google whenever
we needed to configure our database to
talk to our application servers we had
to give our application servers the IP
address of the database and then we had
to allow the database to access an IP
address the range that we knew our
application servers were gonna live in
and this is fine but it is not the most
secure because it means that if your
database moves or if someone starts
spoofing an IP address there are all
sorts of other awful things that can
happen on the internet someone could
theoretically break into your database
that they also have the database
password and
credentials it is much better and also
just is not particularly flexible
because it meant that if we move to the
database around err if we added servers
we had to redeploy everything so what
the cloud sequel proxy does is it makes
it much easier to interact with your
database in a secure way there's a proxy
application that either runs on your
local development machine if you wanted
to do that can't say that I highly
recommend that for a lot of pre prod
scenarios like staging or even
development environments that's not a
horrible way to do things
or it can run on like your App Engine
cluster it's really easy to enable an
app engine in the app dot amyl or in
some of your other compute variations
GCE potentially cloud run and others and
there's just a little application there
and all it does is it listens to all of
your database commands and sends them up
to the other side of the proxy which
lives on GCP it validates that your
credentials are correct your these are
your iam credentials there's a couple
different ways to use them but these are
the IAM credentials that you can control
through either the IAM commands g-cloud
command line or also just through the
cloud console and then it forwards them
onto the database so that you don't
actually have to connect your database
via IP or your servers to your database
via IP and so it basically adds
additional layers of security and also
flexibility by adding a layer of
indirection between your application and
your database which just works better
for a cloud environment where things
move around you might need to connect
applications and it also works better
because you can control the access
control in a much more fine-grain way
because you can know who based on the
credentials not just what IP accessed it
and I think that is correct but there
will be a link in the show notes so that
all y'all can go read the blog posts or
the documentation page and tell me the
bits I got wrong ooh that sounds like a
challenge I like learning things too so
let me see if I understand this
correctly so like the common production
case is that you have a copy this proxy
running on every machine VM kind of
environment and the stuff there doesn't
need to know about passwords or IP
addresses it just talks to the local
proxy and the proxy does often an
integrated cloud way it does need to
know about passwords okay because every
time you're accessing a database you
have to both authenticate into the
machine and then all
so authenticate into the database and
this takes care of authenticating to the
machine got it
basically verifying who can access the
machine but you still need to have your
valid password or account to access the
database because your database account
controls your permissions for the data
in the database so databases contain
very important information and we should
secure them carefully no kidding
somebody's going to disagree with me but
this sounds a little bit like two-factor
off for a database connection in a way
cool thank you for that I learned a lot
and I hope everyone else did too
this is the section where we talk about
where people are going to be and lead on
where are you gonna be okay it's the end
of the year I'm gonna be at home
drinking tea and playing with codes love
it this is gonna be a really easy and
short one because same is true for me
tea and playing with tech and maybe some
games but I'm trying to learn about
Laura
radio communication and silliness with
like argh do we know you like things so
we'll see what happens there on my own
my text not that cool I am still working
on my cloud functions application to
keep my cat in the house I'm hoping that
I will get four more hours to finish it
off so that I can write the blog post
showing how you can use cloud functions
and cloud tasks do you hit an HTTP
endpoint it's actually a reasonable
business case but I'm using it to keep
my cat in the house because my cat can
open doors so this is amazing wait have
you talked about this on the podcast
before like we can't just end without
you I don't think I have I can't I don't
think okay so thank you how do we get
from HTTP give it to doorknobs like hard
house there's an HTTP endpoint that I
can use to lock the doors for my house
via an authentication means there's
actually multiple layers of indirection
there but just you know short version is
I hit a specific HTTP endpoint with
specific credentials and it locks the
doors and then I can trigger that it
also triggers an event when the doors
unlock so you then use code tasks to add
a timer to timeout
and while this particular use case is
completely ridiculous there are a lot of
use cases in business where an event
happens that you can use to trigger a
Claud function
and then you want to sometime later
maybe send a sign-up email or send a
reminder email or something like that
and or maybe not even an email maybe you
want to go hit a slack endpoint or
something like that but you want to do
it on a delay and there's a lot
surprisingly large number of business
cases that are like that I'm just
happening to use a particularly
hilarious one to motivate my application
brothers and yes for everyone listening
there is a much better way to do this I
wanted to play with cloud functions but
it's awesome fantastic thank you have an
awesome holiday playing with that and I
hope everybody had a great podcast and
has a good rest of the month and time
holidays and stuff
[Music]
[Music]
you
you